umber.
And that number is wo ne ine wo David P, this
is something that's a bit touchy and I do
get a lot of questions about this.
It's sort of about like real life hate mail.
Let me just play it and then we'll talk about
it.
Oh, hi David.
My name is Debra and I'm calling from um,
Newfoundland, uh, Atlanta, Labrador anada.
I just listened to your piece about the, that
your latest hatred now.
And I wondered if, um, you'd received any
kind of heat drip mail that was criminal,
right.
And or yet act on it in the main time.
Um, I just wanted to say thank you for all
the great work we're doing.
I think I'm going to use that coupon code.
Um, I think it's a Atrius orty.
Yes indeed.
Ah, and get myself a econd ne.
Uh, we will keep the hatreds crying.
Um, David, thanks so much and take care.
Um, bye.
Bye.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
So listen to the question, is there ever hatred
at mail or hate mail that we get that we would
consider criminal?
But the answer is yes, we do receive things
that warrant the involvement of law enforcement.
And fortunately we've built some great relationships
with um, federal, both federal and local law
enforcement.
And it's, I don't publicize those.
And there are specific reasons why, and I
don't even really think we need to go into
detail, but the answer is yes.
The stuff that, that is where we believe that
it requires the involvement of law enforcement.
And it is unfortunately not an infrequent,
um, it's much more frequent than I would like.
Sadly, we don't put those on the air and those
go directly to law enforcement and um, things,
uh, things sometimes happen as a result of,
uh, those, those inquiries that we do.
But, um, we keep those off the air.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about, so there's this new, there's
new battle lines in the conservative fight,
um, in the LGBT, uh, space, which is uh, pushing
into sports and trans kids.
Okay.
This is the next wave of anti LGBT activism
and we're going to talk about that.
We will also talk about presumably the moving
forward of a proposal that would cut food
stamp benefits for millions of people economically
disastrous, but forget about that morally
and abomination.
And then we will also talk about the misspellings,
the misspellings of many of our most famous
and high profile tweeters, people that tweet.
Um, and what we can sort of deduce from that.
There has been some research done about misspell
high-profile misspellings on Twitter, which
I think you will find interesting.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, wo ways to access it.
Become a member at ww dot join Pacman dot
com or become a patron at Patrion dot com
slash David Pakman show.
I would love to see you on the bonus show
if you will not be partaking.
Then we will have a brand new program, the
David Pakman how at David Pakman dot com.